so first up is breach i think that
breech is a lot stronger than people
think he is breech is b-tier i agree i
think he's weird here too so then we
have sky hawkeye i don't like sky every
time i play against her there's dogs and
cabbages and birds i feel like i'm in
red dead you want to do a hot take and
put her in seats here just put her in a
seat here man cypher i think cypher is
incredibly underrated honestly i think
he's c dear
you want a cam just play c okay what i
think you should understand is just how
incorrect you are in so many different
levels though i mean if you think he's a
b tier we can put a b tier couldn't beat
her okay i feel like ko i feel like he's
b tier i might push him to a a his info
grabbing i think is
unavoidable he does seem kind of dumb a
tier sure let's go ahead prince joy it's
time all right now yeah say what you
have to say to me go for it fringe joy
stands for cedar you know what's the
worst part dmitry what's that i agree
with you